The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So this week
the last final
topic we were taught--
we're really going to talk
about in class is dynamic
programming, so who can tell
me what the key idea in
dynamic programming is?
AUDIENCE: A way of
[INAUDIBLE].
Instead of optimization tools,
you can use [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Sort of.
The key idea is that you don't
want to repeat computations
that you've already
done before.
So you want to find a way to
only do everything once.
So it's a form of laziness.
There are two key attributes for
a problem though that need
to exist for it to be solvable
with dynamic programming.
Can someone tell me
what those are?
AUDIENCE: It's optimal
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
The local optimization
has those.
PROFESSOR: There's overlapping
sub-properties.
[LAUGHTER]
You had all the right words,
just not in the right order.
An optimal substructure.
OK.
Can you describe the first
one, or any one?
AUDIENCE: You get to the end
solution [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So when they say
overlapping sub-problems, it
means that we can take the big
problem and we can break it
down to a slightly smaller
instance of the same problem.
And then we can use the solution
to that smaller
sub-problem in the solution
to our bigger problem.
And then optimal substructure
is closely related.
It's saying that if we get an
optimal solution for one of
those sub-problems, then we can
use that optimal solution
for the optimal solution
of the big problem.
Does that make sense
to everyone?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What's that?
It's closely related.
And so it's--
yeah, it's closely related
but not exactly the same.
So to start off, we're going to
do kind of a function that
we're all familiar with,
is Fibonacci, right.
We've seen this one a billion
times before.
And so it's pretty obvious
where the overlapping
sub-problems are.
The solution to f of N is
f of N minus 1, and f
of N minus 2, right?
And so if I combine the
solutions to these two
instances of Fibonacci, I get
the solution for the big
instance of Fibonacci right?
So on the screen, you have
an example function.
You've all seen this before.
And so what I'm just going to
do is I'm going to run this
Fibonacci function from 0 to 30,
or N equals 29 actually.
And we're going to
look at how many
steps it takes to execute.
When we get to Fibonacci of 29,
it takes about 1.6 million
steps to compute the value.
And if we take a look
at a plot here--
so the y-axis is semi-log, the
blue dots represent the actual
number of steps that the
function took, so the number
of times that it had to perform
the computation.
And then the blue solid line
represents 2 to the N. The red
line is the golden ratio to
the N, which is the tight
bound for this version
of Fibonacci.
And then the green line is a
plot of a quadratic function.
So nothing really surprising
there.
It's pretty inefficient, and
we established that before.
So we could make this more
efficient with dynamic
programming, right?
Let's draw out the call
tree for f of 5.
Doing a lot of writing.
OK.
So if you look at this, we see
that in a lot of places, we're
repeating computations.
So we repeat f of
2 three times.
We also repeat f of 3, this
computation, twice.
The idea behind dynamic
programming is that instead of
repeating these computations
over and over again, we're
just going to compute
them once.
So if we look at the
implementation of this
recursive Fibonacci, we see that
the first recursive call
is going down this
side of the tree.
And so the upshot
is that this--
all the values from f5, f4, f3,
f2, f1, f0, they all get
computed before any
of these branches.
So what we can do is instead of
recomputing f2 and f2 here,
we can just compute it here.
Save off this value somewhere
in some sort of a brain, and
do the same thing for f3,
and f4, but that's
not going to matter.
So when we get to the second
recursive call, say when we're
calling Fibonacci of 3, we
compute f of 2, get f of 1, we
come back up to Fibonacci
of 4, right?
The next recursive call is going
to be to Fibonacci of 2.
But since we've already computed
it, and we've saved
it off in a brain, we can just
look up this value instead of
doing all the computation
again.
So when you have a very small
tree like this, right, it's
not a huge benefit.
But if you have like a lot, like
f of 100, this is going
to make a huge difference.
Is anyone lost?
OK.
So why don't we take a look--
So this is an implementation
of Fib that has an extra
parameter called memo.
And memo is the brain
I'm talking about.
This is where we're going to
stash those computed values so
we don't have to compute
them again.
And when it initially comes in,
if memo is none, that is,
we haven't passed in a
dictionary or if it's like the
first call to this function,
then it's going to set a key
of 0 to 0 and key of 1 to 1.
Those correspond to f of 0 and
f of 1, right, actually.
No one pointed that out?
All right.
So, now it's going to--
after it does that
initialization, it's going to
come down to this if statement,
and it's going to
check for whether or
not N is in memo.
What this is actually
asking is, have we
seen this number before?
When we've been computing this
number, the big Fibonacci
number, right?
So if it's down here, and it's
looking at f of 2, it's
asking, have I seen Fibonacci
of 2 when I've done this
computation before?
And if it's in this tree, then
the answer is yes because it's
seen it down here.
If it hasn't seen it though,
it's got to do the work.
So it's got to actually do
the recursive calls.
And this is when it travels
down this left
branch of the tree.
Does that makes sense?
And all we're going to do
is store it off here.
And then at the end,
we just return
whatever's in our memory.
So why don't we take a look
at how this runs.
So remember, this is 1.6
million with the old
implementation, and
now it's only 57.
And in fact, it's linear and
exactly 2 to the N minus 1, or
2 times N minus 1.
Everyone follow that?
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: There's not too
much we could do.
PROFESSOR: No.
It saves a lot of
work for you.
Because as soon as it--
so let's say that it's computed
f of 4, this entire
sub-tree here.
As soon as it sees f of 3, it's
going to look in it's
brain, and you've already seen
f of 3, and it says, I've
already seen this, so I don't
need to do all this
computation here.
I don't need to do all these
recursive calls.
I just have to return whatever's
in the dictionary.
That's where your
savings come in.
So let's take a look
at another example.
The point is, you can have some
really huge savings if
you write your code right.
So let's look at a different
problem.
Let's say that I have a robot.
And this robot is positioned
on the grid.
Let's say that it has N rows,
and N columns, or M columns.
Your robot is starting
out here, and it
wants to get here.
Your robot though is very
stupid, and it can go only
down and to the right.
The question is, how many unique
paths are there from
the top left square to the
bottom right square, given
those constraints?
If you try and do this
analytically, you'll probably
hurt yourself.
The easier way to do it, or
at least I think so, is to
realize that in order to get to
g, there's only two places
that it can come from.
It can come from here, it can
come from here, right.
So the total number of unique
paths coming into g are the
total number of unique paths
coming into this guy, and the
coming into this guy.
So there's your overlapping
sub-problems, right, and also
your optimal substructure.
If I can figure out these
numbers, then I can figure out
this number, right.
So--
and then these guys, the
same condition applies.
If I know these two numbers,
then I can
figure out this number.
If I know these two numbers,
then I can
figure out this number.
So one implementation--
well, one other thing.
If I get down to this case where
I have a 1 by M grid,
how many different ways
are there to get
from here to here?
One, right?
And then same thing
for M by N right?
So the first crack at this,
here's a recursive function.
All we're going to do is, if
we only have 1 row or 1
column, we return 1.
Otherwise, we're going to look
for the number of robot paths
in an N minus 1 by M matrix and
then the number of paths
in an N by M minus 1 matrix.
So let's take a look.
We're going to do this
on a 14 by 14 grid.
And this will take
a few seconds.
OK.
So there's a lot.
10 million unique paths, and it
took about 20 million steps
to figure it out.
So we're going to pull the same
trick for this problem
that we did for Fibonacci.
We're going to memorize, or
memoize, the different paths
or the different solutions,
except our key is going to be
a little different.
It's just going to be N and M.
So again, if we have--
well, again, if N and M
is not memo, then we
need to compute it.
If either is 1, then we
remember it as 1.
And if they're both greater than
1, then we're going to
look at the number of paths
in N minus 1 by M, and N
times M minus 1.
And then we also know
that the solutions
are symmetric, right.
So it's going to be the same for
an N by M and an M by N.
And just return the solution.
So let's try this out.
We get the same answer, but it
only takes 104 steps to do it.
So it's a pretty huge
savings there.
So the other--
this is an example
of a top-down
dynamic programming solution.
We looked at the big problem,
and we broke it down into two
smaller problems.
We looked at those two smaller
sub-problems, we broke them
down into two smaller
sub-problems a piece.
We can also go from
the bottom up.
And we might want to do
this for a reason that
I'll show in a second.
So I think I needed that.
This is going to go from
the bottom up.
So instead of starting back here
and asking how many ways
I can get from these two guys,
it's going to start at the
beginning and ask how many
ways I can get here.
One, right.
And then here let's imagine that
we only have a 2 by 2.
It's going to look at, again,
the number of ways to get to
the square to the left and
to the square to the
top, and add it here.
Add it here.
So what we're doing here--
what we're doing in this version
is we're growing a
grid towards a solution.
Does that make sense?
This just sets up a matrix.
The top row is going to
be initialized to 1.
First column is going to be 1.
And then for everything else,
we're just going to add the
row above and the column
to the left.
And return whatever's down in
this lower right corner.
So it gets the same solution,
just in a different direction.
So now you might want to do
this because imagine if
instead of 14, we had 1,400.
So this should crash.
Python has a maximum
recursion depth.
If you have too many recursive
columns, it's going to tell
you, I can't go that deep,
and kick you out.
So I have 1,400 rows
and 1,400 columns,
that's a lot of recursion.
But if we do it iteratively,
where we have no recursion,
that's the number of unique
paths, which is a pretty
sizable number.
And that's the number of columns
we made, which for a
1,400 by 1,400 matrix is
not too bad, right.
All right.
So that was an easy one.
So now we're going to go
to little harder one.
Everyone doing all right?
OK.
This is a counting
change problem.
The idea is, let's assume I have
a currency with coins of
a certain value.
I'm not sure where I got the
$0.27 from, but that's
apparently the value for the
coins in our currency.
So the problem is--
let's say that I have
a sum total--
the question is, how many
different combinations of
coins are there that
equal total?
The way to break this down
is-- so does everyone
understand the problem?
So like if I say I want to
give change $0.41 to a
customer, then it's like a
quarter, a dime, a nickel, and
a penny, right?
We can think of the problem
in two ways.
Well, we can break the problem
down into two sub-problems by
first considering what the total
is-- what the number of
combos would be if I use the
largest coin in my set.
We're using at least one
of the largest coins.
And then the other is the number
of combinations if not
using the largest coin.
OK?
So this turned, actually
turns, into a nicer
sub-problem, which is if I have
total minus largest--
so in this case, minus $0.27,
what's the number of
combinations for this
sub-problem?
You follow?
And then this guy can be
formulated as the number--
so I still have total number
of combinations.
But then I take out the largest
coin, so coins is now,
instead of 1, instead of having
$0.27 as the largest
coin, now has $0.25 as
the largest coin.
Does that makes sense
to people?
And so the solution here to
this big problem is the
solution to--
or is the sum of the
solutions to this
problem and In this problem.
Make sense?
All right.
Why don't we take a look at
the first version of this
problem or this implementation.
So we have three base cases.
So the first base case is--
well, first let me explain
the function.
So, total, that's the
amount that we want.
Coins--
it's the set of coins
in our currency.
And I only have $0.05, $0.10,
$0.25, and $0.27, so, oh well.
The first thing we do is check
to see if total is 0.
That means that we're trying to
figure out what combination
of coins is equal to 0.
And of course, there's only
one combination of coins.
There are no coins.
So that actually is 1.
This case--
this is if we're trying a
particular coin that's a
little too large to fit
into our total.
So we wind up going below 0.
That means we can't use that
coin for this particular
total, right.
So there are no combinations
that work for this.
And then this last case is,
if we're no longer using--
if we have no more coins, and
we still have stuff that we
need to make up, like we still
have some value in total, then
that means that this particular
combination that
we're trying out also doesn't
work, so we return 0.
So that's this case, where we've
taken out everything, so
our set of coins is the
empty set, is nothing.
Does that make sense?
So our first recursive call is
looking for the number of ways
without the last coin.
That's this case.
And all we're doing is we're
passing in the total we got
before, and all the coins except
for the largest one, so
the last one.
So we're stricken one off
for each recursive call.
And then the second case here
is if we do use at least one
of the largest coins.
In this case, we're just
going to subtract
that off the total.
And we're going to pass
in coins as is.
Make sense?
And then we just
return the sum.
OK.
So not too bad.
Everyone follow that code?
All right.
So this is without doing any
memoization, it's just using
recursion, breaking it down
into two sub-problems and
figuring out a solution.
But now we're going to use
dynamic programming to
optimize this a little bit.
So in this case, we have
our little memoization
dictionary--
you notice a pattern here?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do you have
an infinite
amount to supply those?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So you're assuming that you
have an infinite number of
$0.27 cent pieces, $0.25
cent pieces, et cetera.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
just add 1's [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: And it's possible
to get below 0.
So let's see.
This is all the same, right?
No surprises there.
But then what we're going to do
is we're going to memoize
on the total that we're trying
to find and the largest
value-- largest currency
piece that we have.
And if it's not in our
dictionary, then we're going
to compute it.
And then once we get the
solution, we're going to
memoize it and return it.
So let's see how this runs.
It could've been by 4.
That make sense to everyone?
No questions?
Wow.
So now let's try a different
formulation.
This one's a little tricky.
Let's imagine that
I have a grid.
And down the rows I have
numbers up to total.
OK, starting from 0.
Across the columns, I have my
different currency pieces.
So the first two implementations
we're going
top down, now we're
going bottom up.
The way you read this is, if I
have a total of 0, this is a
number and my largest currency
piece is $0.05, or $0.10, or
$0.25, or $0.27, it's the number
of coin combinations I
have that will equal
this total, right.
So in this first row, that's
my base case, right.
And then down here, we know
this is all going to be 0,
because if I have
no coin pieces--
So now, the bottom-up way is,
we're going to fill in this
table here.
So we're just going to iterate
through all the totals that
are possible.
And for each total, we're going
to iterate through all
the largest coin
denominations.
Right?
And then we're just going
to do two checks.
We're going to look at the
current total we're looking
at, so let's say that we're on
row one, so our total is 1.
And we're going to subtract the
largest denomination of
currency that we're
looking at.
We start out here.
So we're going to subtract
5 from total of 1.
And that's less than 0.
And when it's less than 0, all
we're going to do is carry the
number of combinations from the
current total to the next
smallest largest denomination.
So if we're at 5 and we know
we're less than 0, that means
we're going to carry
this value over.
And we're now going to
do the same thing
for all these values.
Now let's get to an
interesting case.
So now we're looking at
a total of 5, OK?
When our largest coin is $0.05
and we subtract it from a
total of 5, that's not
less than 0, right?
So that means we're going
to go into the
second branch of f statement.
So again, the same thing.
We're going to look at the
number of ways with the
largest coin.
And to do that, we're going
to use our table.
We're going to look at the
current total, which is 5,
minus the largest coin
that we're looking
at, which is $0.05.
So that's going to index us
into this row because
5 minus 5 is 0.
And then we're going to
look at the current
coin, which is $0.05.
So that's going to
be 1, right?
Well, I skipped a step.
So we're going to get this
value, right, so this is the
number of ways with
the largest coin.
And then we're going to look at
the number of ways without
the last coin, so if this is
the largest coin that we're
looking at, then without it,
this is all we have.
So that's going to be 0.
So 0 plus 1, that's 1.
And then for 10--
so again, this becomes 0.
So the next interesting
one is going to be 10.
Is everyone following so
far what we're doing?
This would be 0.
This is going to be 1 plus 0.
And this is going
to be 1 plus 1.
Making sense?
Make an error?
No, OK.
And then this is going to be
0 Everyone get the idea?
So we're just filling
in this table.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Here?
AUDIENCE: There's only one
way to make 10 plus 5.
PROFESSOR: Because--
the smallest--
so if I had 1 here, like so I
was using a one piece, then
this would be 2.
But because we only have
5, there's only
one way to make 10.
Two 5's.
Make sense?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
because you can either use
one 10 or two 5's.
PROFESSOR: Yes, exactly.
AUDIENCE: So if we're using
the table that as--
so you have $0.05 as the largest
coin, so there's only
one way of doing it using $0.05
as the largest coin?
How come that 1 doesn't go all
the way across the row?
Because if you have $0.25
as the largest coin
you could use $0.05's.
PROFESSOR: You know what,
you're right.
Made an error.
Actually, that would be 0.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What's that?
Yeah, but--
what can I say?
It can be confusing.
To prove that this crazy thing
works, let's run it.
So let's expand this.
Actually, I'm going
to use this.
So all three versions--
what, did I make a mistake?
AUDIENCE: No, it's just how
you expanded the window.
PROFESSOR: Oh, you like that?
AUDIENCE: That's what we--
well, like Tracy's quote is
always really, really small.
But.
AUDIENCE: No worries.
PROFESSOR: It's a program
called Divvy, if you're
interested.
I think it's like $10 on the
Apps store or something, or
maybe it's $5.00.
It just allows you to do those
little grid things, so if you
have lots of windows
and stuff--
and if you need to increase
your font size, that's a
little bit more involved
with Python.
Anyway, so they all give the
same output except for the
number of steps that they take,
so the initial one took
855, the one with the
memoization took 209 steps,
and the one without memoization
but from bottom up
took only 337 steps, so--
it's just-- it's three different
ways of attacking
the same problem.
And objectively, the last two
are better than the first one.
We might think of cases where
we would want to use say the
table-based method over their
recursion method.
Like if we had like lots of
combinations to explore or
some kind of situation where
you got into a really deep
recursion that was too deep for
Python to handle and we
got kicked out like we did for
the number of robot paths.
So that would be kind of like a
criteria for which algorithm
you would choose
over the other.